[Música]
bienvenidos al nuevo capítulo de
historia soy Álvaro Cordero la atención
entre Rusia y occidente por Ucrania ha
puesto el foco en la otan esta
organización militar creada en plena
guerra fría es considerada una amenaza
por Moscú y su expansión hacia Europa
del este es la causa principal por la
que el gremlin Afirma haber desplegado
decenas de miles de tropas en la
frontera ucraniana en La Crónica de
historia de hoy repasaremos por qué se
creó esta organización los motivos de su
existencia tras la caída de la unión
soviética y su papel en la actual crisis
ucraniana para averiguarlo hay que
retroceder hasta el 4 de abril de 1949
ese día Estados Unidos y Canadá junto
con 10 aliados europeos entre los que
estaban Francia y Reino Unido firmaron
el tratado del Atlántico Norte Un pacto
militar defensivo que pretendía alejar
una posible agresión de La Unión
soviética
de las naciones que circulan el
Atlántico Norte eso es absolutamente
falso
con los años otros países europeos
quisieron sumarse al paraguas protector
que proporcionaba la otan Turquía y
Grecia se unieron en 1952 y Alemania
occidental hizo lo mismo en 1955 estos
movimientos propiciaron que desde la
unión soviética se crea si una
organización similar el llamado Pacto de
Varsovia que incluía a la propia URSS y
a sus aliados socialistas en el este de
Europa sin embargo Aunque la atención se
elevó en varias ocasiones la otan nunca
entró en acción pero en 1989 comenzó el
colapso del bloque soviético 2 años
después el Pacto de Varsovia desapareció
poco antes de la desintegración de La
Unión soviética sin embargo Aunque la
principal causa de su nacimiento había
desaparecido la otan No contemplo
disolverse todo lo contrario esta
organización aprovechó para expandirse
gracias a la debilidad de Rusia en el
tablero geopolítico
en este contexto se vieron las primeras
intervenciones en la historia de la otan
en 1995 se bombardearon puntos clave de
fuerzas servovosneas para forzar a estos
grupos afirmar Los acuerdos de Dayton y
poner fin a la guerra en Bosnia 4 años
después la situación Se repitió con los
polémicos bombardeos sobre Belgrado como
represalia hacia Serbia por la limpieza
étnica en kosovo el objetivo era que
cayera el gobierno de slobodan
milosevich algo que finalmente
consiguieron la otan hizo su primera
ampliación tras el final de la Guerra
Fría en 1999 tres antiguos miembros del
Pacto de Varsovia Polonia Hungría y
República Checa se sumaron a la alianza
atlántica y en 2004 se produjo la mayor
ampliación hacia el este con siete
nuevos países en la organización entre
ellos las tres repúblicas bálticas algo
que acercaba a la otan a solo unos
cientos kilómetros de Moscú para Rusia
una de sus principales prioridades en
día internacional era que tras la
disolución de la URSS la otan no
ampliará su poder pero estaba siendo
testigo de cómo Esto no se cumplía para
entender su preocupación solo hay que
analizar el siguiente dato entre 1949 y
1999 solo cuatro estados se sumaron a la
otan pero desde ese año hasta la
actualidad 14 esta situación fue
generando una creciente molestia en el
kremlin que consideró que acuerdos como
la asociación para la paz de 1994 qué
garantizaba la cooperación entre la otan
y los países europeos no miembros
estaban siendo olvidados los rusos
también afirmaron que se desconocía una
promesa verbal de 1990 del secretario de
estado estadounidense James Baker en la
que se afirmó que la otan no se
expandiría Más allá de Alemania en un
célebre discurso de 2007 en la
conferencia de seguridad de Munich
Vladimir Putin ya mostró su descontento
internacional como las reglas y el
sistema completo de un estado
esencialmente de Estados Unidos ha
sobrepasado sus fronteras nacionales en
todas las áreas en la economía en la
política en la humanitario todo está
impuesto por un solo estado A quién le
puede gustar eso
pero a pesar de las quejas de Putin la
expansión Estados Unidos
en Rumanía y Polonia en el año 2010 el
kremlin Consideró que este despliegue
era innecesario y un peligro para su
seguridad aunque la otan justifico que
era para prevenir ataques desde fuera de
Europa la ruptura total llegó en 2014
con la anexión rusa de crimea y el
inicio de la guerra del Don vas en el
este de Ucrania acciones que occidente
consideró ilegales
es en este contexto en que llega la
crisis actual el despliegue de tropas
rusas en la frontera ucraniana responde
al rotundo no de Rusia ante la
posibilidad de Ucrania se sume a la otan
para Rusia esto es una línea Roja en dos
aspectos un objeto político y otro
histórico con respecto al primero Rusia
no se puede permitir el despliegue de
tropas y armamento de la alianza en un
país fronterizo el segundo responde a
los orígenes históricos y culturales
comunes que rusos y ucranianos tienen en
la rus de kiev la alianza atlántica se
enfrenta en las últimas semanas al que
es uno de los mayores desafíos de su
historia hasta ahora se ha explorado la
vía diplomática desde occidente son
varias las voces que han advertido de
las consecuencias que tendría una
invasión de Rusia a Ucrania lo que no
está del todo claro es si realmente es
esto lo que le interesa al kremlin o si
la presión hacia la otan y sus aliados
puede ahora girar en torno a reconocer a
la República separatistas de lugares al
este de un posible paso más en lo que es
una crisis que por ahora no tiene una
solución fácil a la vista con esto
concluimos Gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de France
24.com
[Música]